2022 un año de quiebre para los derechos
reproductivos en eeuu los expertos
alertan de los efectos que derivarían
del fallo de la corte suprema
estadounidense en junio del próximo año
que podría aprobar la petición del
estado de misisipí de reducir el derecho
al aborto a las 15 semanas de gestación
una decisión que podría replicarse en
otros estados y que según afirma
alejandra cárdenas para france24
conllevaría a un problema de salud
pública checarlo vive y se vuelve a
criminalizar el aborto lo único que va a
ocurrir es ganar muchísimos abortos
clandestinos e inseguros y esto ha
disparado y amar la mortalidad materna y
la mórbida
otra consecuencia del fallo el aumento
de procedimientos en lugares con
tendencias más demócratas
estimamos que otros 26 estados
comenzarán a deteriorar el acceso al
aborto para sus residentes en sus
territorios
y se estima que california podría haber
un aumento de 3 mil por ciento en las
pacientes que vienen al estado
la determinación también podría
profundizar la brecha entre las mujeres
que pueden pagar por los viajes con las
que no a las personas que en este país
no tienen acceso buena sesión legal a la
salud y pues en particular a servicios
de aborto son las personas de mayor
vulnerabilidad
que tienen los más bajos recursos y
frecuentemente son personas pues
parcializadas inmigrantes una mayor
demanda abre múltiples desafíos para los
estados receptores que van desde la
creación de nuevas clínicas hasta la
contratación de más médicos y la
protección de las pacientes